bonjour merci à d'être en direct avec
mon sur l'hers et france alors le
président français a reçu à londres dans
un contexte d'épidémie quel regard
portez vous sur ce déplacement
je pense que il faut s'en féliciter
beaucoup la france et le royaume-uni ont
depuis des décennies de très bonnes
relations dans le domaine âme de la
politique internationale sur descamps
questions géopolitiques qui ne sont pas
d'accord sur tout mais dans l'ensemble
c'est une relation d'une grande
importance et reconnu comme tel
des deux côtés et cette visite à une
date symbolique est certainement de
nature à renforcer cette fondation et je
suis sûr que c'est bien pour un bien
dans cette optique que de part et
d'autre elle a été organisée alors pour
parler de la situation à sanitaire au
royaume uni c'est le troisième pays qui
compte le plus de morts après les états
unis après le président c'est d'ailleurs
le premier pays européen
qu'en pensez vous à ce que boris johnson
a bien géré la crise sanitaire qui se
passe actuellement la situation est elle
allée des résultats ont été jusqu'ici
mauvais owen unissent à certains
en ce qui concerne la comparaison avec
la france on peut noter que les règles
de confinement ont été plus strictes en
france et peut-être mieux suivies aussi
dans le transport en commun
il n'y avait qu'une recommandation de
porter de masque et à locales comme
chacun sait en france c'est une exigence
légale avec une amende à la clé pour les
contrevenants la situation s'améliore
quand même au royaume uni
le nombre de morts le moyen glissant le
nombre de morts enregistrés par jour
passé à 146 alors que c'était à 943 je
crois à son point où au mois d'avril
mais dans certaines régions le
nord-ouest par exemple la situation
reste dangereuse et le facteur air qui
mesure le taux de propagation à est
augmentée est même repassé au-dessus de
1 je crois dans l'andante dans certaines
régions alors pour parler de boris
johnson
il y est accusé d'avoir monté plusieurs
réunions de crise par rapport au corps
un avion en tout cas c'est ce qu'il est
dit et on dit de lui aussi qu'ils aient
un peu mon très nonchalant face aux
conséquences du coronavirus est ce que
c'est un avis que vous partagez
globalement non en europe on a pu
constater que toute une série de pays à
commencer par des ta vie suivi par la
france où il vit part d'au moins un muni
suivie par l'espagne ont sous-estimé
grandement la dangerosité de covile 18
heures
c'est le cas donc également au royaume
uni mais c'était dû à une
on peut critiquer après coup mais
c'était quasiment personne n'avait
vraiment pris la mesure de la
dangerosité de la de la chose
dans un premier temps mais comme dans
d'autres pays
d'ailleurs on peut ajouter on pourrait
ajouter les états unis à l a10 tous été
sous-estimée également dans un premier
temps dans un deuxième temps le
gouvernant de boris johnson a appris la
question très au sérieux comme vous
savez je pense
il a lui même été atteint par une forme
assez aiguë de la maladie et y est on a
pu craindre que c'est
ses jours étaient comptés comme comme on
dit finalement il s'en est sorti mais
très fatigués parce que cette île à dieu
voire certains traitements l'hôpital qui
sont qu'ils ont des prisons est ce qu'on
lui reproche maintenant c'est plutôt une
certaine frilosité à ouvrir le pays donc
lui faire une reproche de la au jeu
d'instructions sinon je ne partage
absolument pas cette série je ne pense
pas que ce soit koerber corroborée par
les appelants les fêtes
aujourd'hui il ya un grand débat assez
acerbes même au royaume uni entre ceux
qui prônent un déconfinement plus rapide
plus radicale et ceux qui comme c'est le
cas de boris johnson lui même
aujourd'hui prône une ligne prudente et
et les débats sont très vifs y compris
dans la presse conservatrice des
guerre par exemple qui globalement
soutient fermement le gouvernement a
publié pas mal de pièces critique
critique disons comme le gouvernement
sur ce sujet on pourrait mieux j'avais
et et retourne une trop trop coudre
monsieur thomson merci beaucoup vous
êtes vice-président du parti
conservateur en france merci d'avoir et
en direction arte france